[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George camel joined by the illustrious
Rachel Cruz who also is my co-host on
Smart money happy hour that's right here
we are together answering your questions
America it's a very different show we're
very serious very professional on the
show and then we have a good time on
Smart money happy hour just dishing just
talking like us old girl old gals but
this show is very different you call in
with your questions and we will do our
best to give you Sage advice and that
comes from Rachel sole 8825 5225 is the
number to call and talent I believe is
how I say it is in Provo Utah Talon
welcome to the
show thank you so much appreciate you
guys are taking my call sure how can we
help uh yeah so I am currently working
on baby St two that should be end up
that should or baby step I'm finishing
baby step one should be finishing that
by the end of the month I'm kind of
planning a road map for baby step two on
paying off all my debt um and looking on
paper I'm seeing one of my cars that I
have is uh kind of ugly on paper and
looking at the value of it I'm upside
down a little bit on it um and I'm
wondering if it would be
worth um taking out a loan on my 401k to
pay down what I'm upside down in it and
then to sell it from
there well short answer now you take
that one George I don't like this plan
and we'll we'll talk about why um what
is the car worth and what do you owe on
it so I currently owe
26 five on it and the the at least the
Kelly Blue Book value from what I'm
seeing it ranges from um 18 to 21 and
looking at similar cars on the market
and they you know different classified
ads and like that um I'm seeing like 20
about about around 20 okay so you're
about six grand underwater how much
money do you have in the bank if
anything I have very little okay and
what's your
income uh I currently make uh average uh
um 65 a year okay and it's just on how
much overtime is given to
me what was that are you single it's
just you I'm I'm married and have two
kids okay and is is your spouse working
outside the home no she we're we're on a
single income okay is she able
to
uh she could but we've kind of decided
between the TW between the uh two of us
that she's going to stay home with the
kids okay uh what other debt do you guys
have
Talon uh I we have uh her car um and
then we have which is how much student
loans which is uh
24,000 and we're right on track on hers
like the car is worth
24 yeah okay okay and then how much
student loan
debt uh we have around six grand
6,000 yep
okay that helps us okay so back to the
401K loan situation the reason you don't
want to do that the only time we would
tell people hey tap into that 401k is in
case of emergency and by that I mean a
foreclosure or bankruptcy but never just
a payoff debt to help you get out of
this bind and there's two reasons one
you're going to uh decimate all of the
future growth of that money and so if
you take out a $5,000 loan even if
you're going to pay it back over time uh
the possibility of that money growing
for for you in that time will hurt your
brain to see compounded growth over the
next few decades and number two you're
going to pay taxes and penalties on that
money which means you're taking a you
know 30 35% hit just to get out of this
debt so I'd rather see see you use
future income to get out of this mess
versus trying to rob Peter to pay
Paul Y and I'll say this Talon you know
you guys are well over you're getting
close to your annual income in car debt
I mean you guys are right at that
$50,000 Mark of car debt and and our
recommendation is always not to have
cars worth anything on Wheels we say
engines and wheels more than half of
your annual income and so you guys are
beyond that talent and so um you know if
if if I woke up in your shoes honestly
you got two kids at home you have a wife
um your family and I'm like I think I
just would want some relief and so if I
were you I would I would look at selling
both of these cars you you'll have to
take out a small loan for the difference
and a small loan just to get you know to
buy to be able to buy another vehicle
but um I would just want some relief
from this and the amount of stress that
you're probably carrying over a
car yeah it's not worth it do you know
what I mean and you guys can go get a
great car again um not you know it's not
that you guys can never drive a great
car but I mean this is a lot of your
income that is that is wrapped up in car
payments right now Ian how how much how
much is your car payment how much is her
car payment a month I'm just curious so
mine is about
587 and hers is 500 okay so over a,
bucks we get free over $100 yes and then
I mean if you think about it Talon like
you do that and yeah you'll have a small
loan but that means I mean that that
frees up money to be out of completely
out of debt in probably seven months and
then be able to save an emergency fund
you have no money in the bank right now
and so that's stressful I mean you guys
are one life event or one decision away
of this going spiraling down real quick
and and not having the option of like
should we sell or not these cars we're
going to have to to be able to do X Y
and Z if you don't get a paycheck in
right before they get repoed right I
mean like that that's and I don't I'm
not trying to like base all these
decisions off of fear but it's just the
reality of where y'all are and you're so
normal Talon like like this is what
everyone does it's what everyone does
but everyone you're not even special
according to Rachel
Cru but like it's just not worth the
stress and as your and you know and I
have three kids at home and I'm like and
just even the stress your wife probably
feels of like man you know we don't have
money in the bank like we don't have a
lot of save so just the entire situation
talent I would flip it on its head I
would probably just sell the cars and
just just for the sense of a radical
change in your life it'll free you guys
up emotionally financially and then
reevaluate like all right what you know
we want to buy something else so let's
let's look at replacing it here in the
next year you know what I mean like you
you'll have have the option to do that
soon but just for the moment of relief I
that's almost you got a few decisions to
make so this is how it would play out
Talon you would go to your local credit
union you'd get a loan for 15K and that
would cover your underwater portion and
give you guys a little bit of money to
get some beater cars we're talking you
get a $4,000 car she gets a $5,000 car
and the other six will get cover the
underwater portion get it okay so then
you have these beater cars you still
have her car you could sell freeing up
that payment at that point and I would
encourage you to do both cuz here's the
other side of the coin it's either this
or she's got to get to work and bring in
income I mean staying at home is a
luxury or you're going to be able to
work extra or you you got to take on two
jobs to bring your income up 80 90 grand
yeah cuz by April you guys will have
your student loans you know paid off and
then you'll have that $155,000 loan uh
and just working and again working extra
cut and lifestyle all of it and I would
I would want to pay that off in N9
months you know what I mean like you
look up next Christmas you guys would be
in a totally totally different Financial
situations yeah this is like triple
bypass surgery is what you're about to
go through but you're going to have some
big relief on the other side ma'am
relief and sleep you'll have peace I'm
going to give you three months of our
budgeting app every doll premium to help
you guys make a plan for all of this
money cuz I want you to call back and
celebrate with us when you're debt free
thanks so much for the call this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the Ramy show I'm George
Campell joined by Rachel Cruz this hour
this is a show for you about you and the
number to call Isle
5225 now as I mentioned I'm uh
co-hosting with my friend Rachel crew
and we also co-host smart money happy
hour which is one of the hottest shows
on the Ramsay Network and a time I'll
just say that well why would why do you
think that is here's my theory okay I
think people want a light-hearted casual
conversation easy listening where they
can laugh and then they accidentally
learn something oh that's good that's
the way I see it yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like you're kind of ease dropping
in a conversation with friends you're
part of the happy hour I don't know if
you wish that we were your friends
that's that would be ideal Rachel
obviously that's Rachel VI I want to be
your friend let's just say that I'm not
accepting applications for new friends
right now I have a newborn Rachel
priorities but one of our episodes that
we did that became one of our highest
ones 113,000 views exp and this is what
it was called explaining our most hated
Financial advice and for some reason
people really the haters showed up as as
well as the fans yes so we're going to
go through that you know people people
do not like us sometimes and we're going
to talk about it
it was also cathartic for me can I be
honest it felt good to just like have my
rebuttal oh yeah my retorts yeah my
RS okay okay uh you go that first one
George this is this is a very you thank
you I don't know if that's a compliment
but I'll take it the first one we say is
crypto is a terrible way to invest and
spend your money we say it and all the
crypto I'm going to say dudes it's not a
lot I just don't feel like a lot of the
women haven't ran into a lot of women a
lot of women don't get because do the
guys are like women use something called
logic a lot where his guys are like it's
like a flex it's like come on man crypto
now you know women have girl math and so
they're not innocent here true that's
true we can justify some spin crypto
from the very beginning I was just like
scratching my head about crypto and I
thought well maybe I'm not dumb enough
to understand and the more I looked into
it the stupider it got and now on the
other side of it we kind of all know it
was a farce just not good and the reason
is I'll give you a real reason crypto is
not based than anything it's just based
on hype when you even buy a single share
of a company you're hoping that the
company produces more profit and revenue
whereas crypto is just I made a coin
this is the coolest hottest coin come
get my coin and so it's very multi-level
marketing Vibes and so I always joke
that crypto is just Mary Kay for young
men for that reason which no offense to
the Mary Kay ladies okay there are some
some yeah Die Hard Mar they're out there
so that's that the second thing people
just yeah they don't care for us on uh
you shouldn't use credit cards ooh we
talk about this a lot that increasingly
is controversial yeah and people you
know it's because the points and the
airline miles what they get from it they
claim is is worth it um but when you sit
in our seat we talk to so many people
where credit cards are not a blessing
it's not a thing that has helped people
it's actually gotten people into a lot
of trouble and they end up being in a
financial position where the credit card
company is winning and they're not
winning and we want you to win and then
you can go through all the you know the
amount of stuff that doesn't work when
it comes to the points and the airline
miles playing the game you can go
through the moral side door of they get
to you get these points and you get this
this cash back and you get the airline
miles and everything because other
people are not paying off their cards
Banks make their money off of interest
and so they're making all this money off
of people that are struggling and then
you know reaping the benefits so it's
like it's just a gross it's a gross
thing the way around to me and I'm like
if you have a debit card like just pay
for everything in the present and then
go pay for your Southwest flight like
just save up bud and save up it's so
much more freeing and statistically what
you save by not paying on a credit card
in turn could actually help you have
hundreds of dollars throughout the year
to spend on an airline ticket that you
pay for and I'm going to call out all
the ramay fans who they're they're what
we call is where they go I did
everything but I still have my credit
card I pay it off every month Rachel so
I'm fine
and I've convinced a whole bunch of
people to try a 30-day Credit Card
Challenge where they just oh I saw this
put it in a block of ice and we're
starting to get the results and there
was an interesting someone just said
this I thought it was interesting they
said a few months ago I decided to ditch
the Apple card and just use the money I
have I just wanted to try it out they
said I've definitely seen a noticeable
reduction in my spending and I've
created more margin in my budget for
savings and they said it's just the
little things there's something about
checking my balance inst seeing it
instantly go down after a purchase that
really worked to optimize my spending I
go out to lunch less I buy less extra
stuff at the grocery store you just make
more intentional decisions and so it's
your money and you even you you're the
perfect spender as I call them you're
still spending more than you would have
it's true all right next uh next save
$1,000 emergency funds people are like
inflation 2023 this is the same advice
you all gave in 1993 you know shouldn't
it change with expenses being higher and
things being more expensive that's a big
one and funny enough when Dave came up
with this principle baby step one 30
years ago $1,000 wasn't enough back then
to get the new HVAC system and cover the
big life emergencies and so the
principle of it is it's meant to be a
starter emergency fund it's Dave started
this because people were trying to get
out of debt but they'd have these little
ankle biters that would knock them back
and knock them back and so it's the goal
is to cover the ankle biters if you have
a big emergency number one we want you
to have good insurance in place to cover
some of that the health stuff and number
two you pause the baby steps you save up
fast sell stuff whatever you need to do
to cover the expense most of these
emergencies are not the money's due
today or else the house is getting
foreclosed on right that's right that's
right yeah so yeah the Thousand it's
meant to be a quick step two 30 days or
less because we want you to get traction
and so much of personal finance is is
behavior change and for some people they
can't even cover a $400 emergency in
cash yeah four out of 10 people have
zero in savings right is what we found
so even $1,000 may feel like an uphill
battle but when you do it quickly and
you have it and then you can move on to
paying off debt that that's what it's
there for it's for the quick win it's
for the ankle biter stuff that comes up
in order to pay off the debt which
leaves us to number four George pay off
your debt smallest amount to largest
amount regardless of interest rates this
where the math nerds show up all the
math nerds were like why in the heck
would you not pay off the 25% credit
card versus you'll save $300 in interest
Rachel if you pay off the highest
interest first that's so dumb and I'm
like or you could have paid zero in
interest if you never went into debt so
why are we having this theoretical disc
so silly but the reason we do it again
is what I was saying earlier is is these
quick wins and when you pay off that
smallest debt even if it's a $400 credit
card bill that's been just like laying
around right you pay it off you start to
actually win and you start to feel like
oh my gosh I can do this and so that's
it's a powerful motivator yeah getting
out of debt is way more about Hope and
momentum and progress than it is about
mathematical interest and we've done the
math the amount is negligible about how
much you're really going to save by
doing the Avalanche and I just have not
seen people come in drov saying Rachel I
did the debt Avalanche and that's why we
got out of debt it's likely you'll stay
in debt longer or give up or fall off
the wagon if you don't see that progress
fast all right last but not least uh if
crypto was yours George I feel like this
is
mine married couples to combine
accounts you would think that I just
told you you got three heads Rachel
telling us to do that yeah I mean like I
don't even I mean it like people get so
mad my last two on Instagram George my
my the last two reals I've done about
this over like 3 million views each and
all in the comments they're like this
woman has says a woman says a woman
woman that's what a lot of them say and
I'm like I'm sorry can I go out on limb
and say those guys are single and I'm
like yes just going to say that out loud
oh man people get pissed about this well
they see joint bank accounts as she's
going to take you to the cleaners that's
the very toxic mentality that some
and I always have the ASC you guys and
and on the show we do this and we've
actually had callers that call in with
situations and we tell them the opposite
of this advice if there's an abuse
situation if there's an addiction that's
not being addressed like if there are
things that you have to do to keep
yourself safe absolutely like absolutely
I am not against that but if you're just
the married couple out there both
bringing in an income but she my money
and her money she pays these bills I pay
these you go on vacation they get the
hotel you get the I mean your roommate
you are acting like your roommates and
it's never just about the money it's
never just about the account it's the
idea that you actually don't see
yourself fully as a team and don't fully
trust your spouse and if that is you
then you need to ask like okay why is
that because there's probably going to
be other issues going on that are going
to come up in other parts of your
marriage so we can go on and on about
this yall but I'm telling you people
that win with money when you're married
you see yourself as a team you win
faster and I think you and your and your
marriage becomes better so many people
have stood on the stage George to scream
their debt free and they talk about how
much how unified they are well it's
transparency accountability
communication you know all the Hallmarks
of a great marriage be married be be a
team so anyways there there you go that
is our most hated Financial advice and
we hate you're only fueling us this is
the Ramsay
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George camel
joined by Rachel Cruz this hour the
number to call is
8825 5225 you jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money Derek is up
next in Minnesota Derek welcome to the
show Derek are you with us hey guys how
are you doing we're doing well how are
you pretty good uh so my question is is
I qualify for a VA home loan I'm in
college right now so I'm not looking at
buying a house but probably in a couple
years once I graduate I'm looking for it
okay and I'm wondering what the
advantage of your 15 conventional loan
versus a VA home loan would be cool okay
so talk to us about this home purchase
are you out of debt are you do you have
an emergency fund how far away are you
from this
decision uh well I got I got about uh
year and a half until I graduate I have
no debt I'll have a fully funded
emergency emergency Fun by that point
and I already have a job offer
afterwards which would be roughly about
$775,000 a year awesome way to go man
yeah crushing and thank you for your
service as well so are you a veteran
yourself yeah I'm a I'm a vet myself I
just just got out of the army a month
ago oh wow amazing very cool okay so
let's talk through the VA loan versus
the 15 year so the 15-year loan is as
conventional as it gets so there's not
going to be any special fees or anything
like that there's a set fixed interest
rate and it's a 15-year term and it's
that simple the VA loan uh there's
virtually no down payment so the reason
people find the VA loans attractive is
you can get in this thing with 0%
down the problem with that is that means
broke people can get into a house which
can make them broker because they have
no equity and if the market shifts like
it has been they could be underwater on
this house with too big of a payment on
top of other fees and so the VA loan
does have an extra fee called a funding
fee which will add 1 and a qu% up to a
little over 3% of the loan amount which
will make your overall payments and your
interest higher and there's also a lot
of property requirements that you have
to look into so there are some
restrictions there and uh do you have
any service connected
disabilities uh just a little bit but
nothing nothing that affects my job I
just get a just get 10% for for that so
it's not too much there are situations
where if disability rating is high
enough that funding fee can be waved
which can make this a decent option but
those circumstances are very unique and
so if I'm in your shoes if you're going
hey the 15year is crazy unaffordable
that would make me question if you're
ready to buy a
home gotcha so I would want you to have
a good down payment before you jump into
this yeah overall Derek the VA home
loans usually are just more expensive
because of all the fees and everything
and then just like George said it
doesn't require much of a down payment
and we always say somewhere between 5 uh
to 20% down um so again th those are the
those are the big differences so if I
were you I probably would just go with
the conventional 15% or 15year loan um
and yeah and you can compare different
interest rates if there's difference
there maybe that actually will save you
um if the VA loan for some reason has
you know a lower interest rate but I
would I would ask um ask around and look
at your different options when you're
ready to buy a home I would not buy it
while I'm in school um and don't feel
like you have to buy just cuz you've
graduated and have a great job you could
even rent for a little bit and I I mean
if I were you Derek I would I mean I
would save up you know 5 to 10% for a
down payment regardless of which loan
you choose to go with but I would
probably just go with the 15year
conventional loan if you if if it were
me gotcha does that help you
out yeah it does I was the only reason I
was asking is because you know in like
college you know a few thousand feels
like a lot you know so I always keep
thinking about the buying versus renting
for a couple years after graduating and
whatnot and stuff like that so no it's
great that you're thinking that far
ahead and what I would do if I was in
your shoes is start crunching some
numbers and go hey the homes in my area
that I would want to go for are
$250,000 okay so how much down payment
do I need to get that mortgage payment
to be about a quarter of my take home
pay of my after tax income and so
that'll help you start to get a picture
of what you're actually aiming at cuz
right now there's this Pie in the Sky of
I want to be a homeowner which is great
but having those very specific goals is
going to help you take the next steps so
thank you for your service we're wishing
you the best man Joel is up next in
Modesto California Joel welcome to the
show hey George hey Rachel thanks for
taking my call sure how can we
help so my wife and I are on baby step
two uh we just moved into our home into
September we're
renting and essentially uh we're down to
our last payment which is my wife's C
it's a 2019 Kia Soul and we are just
debating about whether or not we should
sell it um and get uh a return on that
and clear up all of our debt a return
you say tell me more about this return
what's the car worth and what do you
owe yeah so currently we owe 5600 so by
the end of the year it'll be about five
grand and then uh we could flip it for
about 10 between 10 and 11,000 okay you
could sell it for 10 to
11,000 yeah if we did private sale
that's that was the K and then you take
that five grand and get a different
car yeah I was thinking either just
another Soul or just anything that we
could get that was you know relatively
reliable it is our only car and my wife
and I both work how much do you guys
make a
year so currently uh I'm per DM I'm
looking to get a full-time job but uh
our income's a little bit variable but I
would say we're in between
the 35 to 5,000 a month bringing in if
we're both if we if we both have a good
month it's about five grand after tax
after tax and in California I feel like
that would disappear pretty
fast yeah well um it definitely goes by
at the beginning of the month our rent
is 1,500 which is actually pretty good
for our housing situation we have a
three bedroom um but yeah it does it
does go by with all the expenses and
groceries and such so yeah um I mean
Joel if you guys found another great car
for five grand you could do this deal
but also you know if you told me it was
20 grand that's one thing but five grand
knock knock that out just yeah keep
paying on it if it's been a reliable car
I don't know that it's worth the spread
on this thing cuz what I don't want you
to do is call us back and say hey we got
that car for 5 grand it's given us a lot
of issues and it's our only car now
we're in a real buy so we're going to go
get a new car for 50 Grand that's
usually the emotion the emotional roller
Co y found a car for that price that you
guys that you feel real good about and
you're like yeah we're great with this
and it's I just don't know that it's
worth the hle yeah but um but it's just
five grand I think you guys can just pay
that
off okay yeah no and honestly we were we
were thinking that that's that's what my
wife has been trying to tell me I think
just uh just the weight of the you're
ready for it Joel you're ready to be
done
yeah ex I'm ready this is like you throw
in the towel we can just clean this up
and this is your last debt so how much
debt have you guys paid off in this
process uh yeah we funny enough we
actually paid uh my wife's, credit card
the day after our uh daughter was born
good we've been um we've been doing good
and uh I want to say alog together we've
paid off about about four or five cran
yeah since we've been married awesome
good for you guys that's awesome I think
increasing the shovel is going to be the
key to getting rid of this step FAS I
would have an aggressive goal and say
hey we got to be able to throw 1,000
bucks a month of this thing and be done
in under six months then you go okay
what's the Gap we can throw 700 a month
now how do we get an extra 300 bucks a
month yeah I'm going to go do these side
hustles you go do this that to me is
very that motivates me to find out what
the Gap is and then get there and set a
goal that's a little bit uncomfortable
for you yeah yeah yeah would you say um
uh would you say that with our daughter
she's four months old um would you say
that we're still in a little bit of St
mode because I guess that's kind of my
only hesitancy with you know I want to
knock out the debt but I also want to be
here for kind of these you know this
Precious first year so what what would
you guys say about that well stor mode
is usually hey let's wait until mom and
baby are home they're healthy they're
safe then let's continue and so
technically you're outside of those
those boundary lines and I think at this
point the best thing you can do your
4mon old is not going to remember dad
doing side hustles right now yeah I was
going to say Joel it it only gets harder
if I already to be honest so for now I'm
like I would just put my head down get
it done with and then you're going to
look up and be like okay we're free from
that we can get our time back and all of
it so uh I think it only cuz then she's
going to be looking at you and being
like Dad Dad they're going to start
talking and then you're like I don't
want to leave I don't want de free
that's really encouraging Rachel as a
father of a now two-month-old she's like
it's only going to get harder you idiot
good luck with that thank very
encouraging congrats Joel
you guys will get there soon enough my
friend this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the The Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cruz hey
if you're a new listener to the show
first of all welcome we're glad you're
here don't know what brought you here
but you know we we're blessed to have
you and if you want to dive deeper on
all the stuff we're talking about the
Ramy baby steps so on and so so forth
you can go to ramsy solutions.com and
click on the get started button and
we'll help you figure out the next best
step for your financial Journey based on
where you're at today that's Ramy
solutions.com click get started all
right let's get to the phones Isabelle
joins us in San Diego Isabelle welcome
to the
show hi so I'm a freshman in Community
College here in California and I'm 16
and I have a guaranteed spot uh
transferring to whatever institution I
like tag to and my parents are moving
out of state this year which means I
only have one year of instate tuition
and I have a I will have a full ride if
with that inate tuition and I have
enough credits where I can graduate in
one year after I transfer but in order
to do that I would have to pay 12K for
summer classes in total and that would
be the only cost and if I do it in more
than one year it would cost me over 60k
for the living expenses and everything
so this is my only option wow so your
options are pay 12K or 60
yeah and so 12K is obviously what I'm
going with
um and the thing is my parents cannot
afford that 12K is way too much
especially in a couple of months and
there's no way they're going to be able
to afford it I can't work a job um I I'm
currently taking 30 credits I'm going to
be taking 36 next semester and I also
homeschool my sister I just do not have
the time to work a job and also my
parents commute so there's no way for me
to get to a job there's a throw of
issues I can't work a job I can't save
up for it so the only option would be
loans the thing is I'm going to be 16 at
the time still at the time where I have
to pay it and my parents don't want to
help me take out loans so I think my
question is how do I convince them or
find another way to pay for it okay um
wow a lot going on here yeah yeah okay
um first of all are you like some kind
of Prodigy I'm so confused and impressed
at the same time no um I graduated high
school at 15 because I took an exam
where in California let they
discontinued it this year but they let
you graduate early if you pass an exam
with certain things so you are a
prodigy no you're really smart for real
but for real though Isabelle because
that's going to be part of my answer you
said you're graduating in one year okay
so so I want to make sure I get all this
right because I think there is a plan
okay I I feel very hopeful I feel very
hopeful okay so you are you are 16 you
are in community college now and it's
free and you're but but the problem is
your parents are going to moving out of
state when are they moving out of state
uh at the end of this year and for the
you for the college I'm going to be
transferring to um you can you they do
your tax forms for financially the year
before so I'm going to be a resident for
this year so it'll be free but the next
year so my second year there it won't be
free so I have to do it in one year
which I can 2024 is
what like in
2024 2024 to 2025 is when I'm going to
be transferring and that's going to be
my only year and that's going to be your
year but it's still free
then yeah it's still free except for the
12 for the summer classes okay so my
question is what state are they moving
to oh um Nevada and are you not going
with them uh no because I'm going to be
transferring cool so you're going to be
you're going to be living by you're
going to be on your own at at 17 years
old 17 yeah 16 17 years old and you are
going to be technically what a junior in
college with your
credits uh with my credits I'll be a
senior you'll be a senior okay so how
many credits are
left with this 12 Grand because this
understand the summer school thing so
how many credits are in the summer
school
program okay so I'm going to be
transferring with 70 I need 120 total
I'm going to be taking 20 over the
summer which is doable because I took 20
over the summer but but the 20 but those
20 cost 12 Grand and you can't do that
right yeah those 20 cost 12 Grand so
those don't count because you may not be
able to do this summer is what I'm is
what I'm going to be getting at so but
you'll be able to get a hundred of the
other credits done free right so you
have 20 credits left and the 20 credits
30 do what
after uh I'm transferring with 70 I have
to do 20 over the summer and I'll have
30 left in the year and those are free
the 30 left are free okay so you have 20
you have 20 credits that you need they
cost 12 Grand you don't have 12 Grand
we're not going to tell you to take out
loans Isabelle so you have 20 credits
left to get a college degree yes so what
I would do
Isabelle is I would look at schools in
Nevada and I would say hey I'm going to
for a year stay here in California Get
It Free and then in order to get these
20 credits I'm going to be moving
schools in Nevada and here's the
beautiful thing Isabelle you are
brilliant you are 16 years old
as a basically a junior in college right
now and so whether it takes you for
those 20 credits a full semester to do
you're used to do it you're you're doing
double that now right so so you're going
to be doing half of that in Nevada
taking instate tuition from your parents
applying for every scholarship and
grants and you're going to and you're
going to do it it's going to look a lot
different than your plan but I'm telling
you Isabelle I at 16 years old I would
not take out $112,000 I don't not even
able to cuz your parents won't pay for
it or won't sign it which is good on
them I'm proud of them I am so I think
you you're going to have
to look at multiple options and and
lower your expectations some and and
there's no rush either Isabelle like I
know like you're moving a million miles
per hour you are and you're doing all of
this cuz I get cuz it's free and you
want to take advantage of that so I'm
all for that but everything else can
just take a breath take a breath and you
can slow it down do it over the course
of a year at when you're eight 18 years
old and work part-time and do it then
and and graduate debt free you know the
the the rush and the urgency is going to
cause you not to be able to have the
capacity to look at all the different
options out there and it may cause you
to make a bad decision because you're so
laser focused on one way does that make
sense uh yeah I just like had a question
about that because I thought about that
too like taking credits in Nevada the
thing is they don't um for you
they won't transfer I called them and
everything they won't transfer those 20
credits so I have to take those 20
credits over the summer so my plan kind
of is contingent on convincing my
parents to co-sign it no and it's like
really
stressful no I not do that don't do that
Isabelle no you I would look at other
options maybe you don't go to the school
maybe you just go to Nevada go to Nevada
with your parents at the year and go to
school in Nevada and get scholarships
and grants and graduate from a school in
Nevada California there's other places
that have degrees other than just
California if this plan is so conent
every variable working which scares me
yes and if I'm your big sister Isabelle
I'm like this is not it's not wise we
talked to so many people on the show
Isabelle so many people and they are
still paying off loans almost every
colar we have with debt still has
student loans and and and there's a way
around this and and I'm and I feel
confident in that because of how
freaking smart you are and so the
scholarships and grants and everything
else like there's still going to be
there's going to be options out there
for you the other piece of the puzzle is
you said you're homeschooling your
sister where is she
going she's um okay so I'm going to stop
s schooling her because they expect me
to transfer by the end of this year um
one of my brothers is going to start
staying home and doing that okay
wouldn't that free up some time for
you um it's going to be about end next
year so still for this um semester I'm
going to be home schooled in her and
next semester oh you're but you're your
parents are moving without her without
her no no no they're they're going um
okay so for this year from 2023 to 20124
I'm going to be homeschooling her and
then they're going to move at the end of
this summer
oh yeah and then my brother's going to
go homeschool her but okay can we delay
their move why is what's the urgency for
them to
move they're buying a house and they've
already bought
it I have no clue but they said we're
buying a house we're moving it's um they
probably went out of California
my mom's been here for 50 years she's
been paying taxes since like longer than
I've been alive she just does not want
to be here I know in my head though I'm
like if I'm able to let my daughter go
to school debt free by sticking around
for a few more months I'm like that
would be ideal but it sounds like that's
not part of the equation I mean that
that that's out of your control Isabelle
you're not going to be able to to oh man
so I mean I honestly girl I would just
be looking at other options and you're
so young it's not like you're 24 still
trying to get your undergrad degree I'm
like you have time time is on your side
so slow it down slow it down and look at
options do this wisely you don't need
debt Isabelle don't need that don't need
it and here's one more piece of homework
since you're very good at it go watch
our free documentary borrowed future you
can watch it on YouTube go to Borrowed
future.com check that out and you'll see
why Rachel has such urgency I'm proud of
you girl to help you go to school Dee I
think you're smart great you got this
that puts this hour of the ramsy show in
the
books
[Music]
n
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel joined by
Rachel Cruz this hour and it's a free
call atle 8825 5225 if you've got a
question a conundrum maybe you just need
us to settle the score between spouses
or family we're happy to do whatever you
want on this show and Hannah's going to
kick us off in akran Ohio this hour
Hannah welcome to the
show hi thanks for having me sure what's
going
on so I am 22 uh my boyfriend's 23 and
my question is all of our debt will be
paid off by April of 2025 that's credit
card two
vehicles and um yeah credit card and two
vehicles all we have left will be our
new mortgage we just acquired last year
but our problem is our house is sitting
on land that's not in our name so should
I stay on our plan to pay everything off
now in 2025 or keep that extra money
start piling into a savings to put a
down payment on the property by this
next year so you're looking to buy the
land yes how did that not happen with
the sale of the house when you guys
bought the house what was the
the original deal was that me and my
boyfriend were looking for a house we
couldn't get approv for a house by
itself so we bought a modular home and
my grandma said oh you can put it on my
property um and then you guys can
eventually when you can buy the property
and keep it in the family name okay cool
so we did that um and she has just been
letting us have it here so it's not just
some smojo that we have it on it is
family sure however she needs to get out
of her debt that she has on the property
so ideally we don't want to cut her
short on buying the property just to pay
off what she has but we also want to
give her a fair price for it so we've
been here for about a year we can
financially I think buy it by end of
next year but I don't know if I should
stockpile all my extra I'm putting into
paying off my credit card and our two
vehicles or put it towards a down
payment okay um can we go like a little
high level conversation here Hannah for
a second yeah um okay so when you are
talking about your finances with your
boyfriend you're using a lot of like we
statements we're doing this our debt all
of it so just doing this for as long as
we have um when you are not legally
married there is not an
hours we conversation it's a Hannah's
conversation and what's your boyfriend's
name Joey
Joey yes and Joey's money right so like
like these there's gon to be two
separate Lanes here and I know that's
going to be difficult for you to kind of
untangle in your head because it has
been so unified but what ends up
happening is is that you combine
emotionally acting like you're married
combining accounts uh paying on each
other's Dead all of it without any legal
representation no legal documents here
that if something happens and I'll say
if um that it's a complete mess and our
job is to be there for the people when
it's a complete mess so those are a lot
of the calls and some of the the stories
that we hear on that side so what I have
learned is as separate as you can live
that could be financially physically all
the things like as separate as you can
live until you're married it is it is a
cleaner break there there there is
something about it that that it just
makes it cleaner on an emotional and
financial side so I'm going to ask you
Hannah how much do you bring in with
your job what do you make 50,000 you
make 50,000 okay how how how cards do
you do you have any do are any of your
credit cards have his name attached to
them at all or are they just are their
credit cards with just Hannah's
name just the credit card that's in my
name he has his own that his he pays so
how much how much do you have in your on
your in your credit card how much debt
do you have on your credit card 2400
2400 okay perfect and then you have a
car is it just under your name one of
the cars yes okay and how much do you
owe on that one 5,000 5,000 perfect okay
and what does Joey make a year 880,000
880,000 perfect and what does um uh for
his credit cards how much does he
owe only like a thousand a thousand
perfect and what about his
car 29 29 truck 29,000 okay perfect okay
cool okay so what I would do Hannah is I
would be working to pay your using your
50k to be paying off your credit card
you paying off your car car and he's
working his plan you can do it at the
same time but I would not be mixing
numbers and you guys have your own plan
now the
mortgage is it in both your
names it is we have to do it that way to
get approved yes because you guys can't
you couldn't afford it otherwise so
right um okay so that's done so my next
piece of advice then would be
to if if you decide on your own Hannah
to put to to buy this property which I
don't think you can afford right now
with on your grandmother's property I I
I don't I don't see that happening soon
and if I were Joey I would not be tying
my name into land deeds and loans and
all of it with a family loan that on a
family property that I'm not I'm not
legally bound to like he's the one in
honestly anah he'd be the one that gets
screwed in this whole situation if you
guys break up um so my next thing would
be are been are y'all do what I said I
hope not it's been eight years yeah
Hannah and y'all are 22 and 23 you the
only reason we're not married is because
we don't have the funds to do that there
isah Hannah Hannah wrong answer you're
telling me you had the funds to get a
mortgage but not to get married go to
Walmart and buy a silver a silver bands
go on Amazon I could go right now on
Amazon and get you guys two r
for
$9.99 you go to the cous and get married
go get married do it I've said that but
it's not good enough it's not special
enough Joey for him or for you for him
he's making excuses you guys are acting
like you're married anyways so what does
it what do what does a certificate do it
didn't change it that much so he wants
to become a real estate Mogul with you
but not put a ring on
it he's making
excuses he's heard it from both sides my
dad and okay let me just tell you this I
okay you should be glad Rachel's on this
call cuz I am my blood is boiling you
can add in I just your life is like a
common core math problem it's so messed
up it hurts my brain you guys got
yourself into a mess and you're digging
a whole Deeper by getting entrenched in
Grandma's financial situation taking on
land debt on top of a mortgage that's in
both of your names but you're not
married to help Grandma out
right yeah did you hear how crazy that
sentence
was I know and I know it was a crazy
situation how about this how we back out
of this land deal cuz we can't afford it
and we're 22 trying to figure out our
life I think we get out of this modular
home number one that modular home is
going down in value it's not a great
investment anyways so I would get out of
that thing as soon as you could good
luck finding another renter for it
right yeah that was kind of from the
beginning of why it even happened but we
have to think about the future when we
make decisions today and I really pray
that we can resolve this that you guys
can get out of this mess that you get
married that you step foot uh get on the
right foot with this thing but right now
contining with this deal no you can't
you can't afford it Hannah you can't
afford it and it's not your
responsibility either in this so I would
find yeah separate those finances you
guys work your plan tell Joey to go on
Amazon I can send them a link and is
I'll send them a
[Music]
link
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation in
prayer is hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you three months free to get
started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Pao is giving you 90 days
free imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hall.com
Ramsey today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hall.com
Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cruz we're
co-hosting the Ramsey Show today but we
also co-host smart money happy hour
which you can find on YouTube podcast
Spotify Ramsey Network app wherever you
like to listen and uh if you want a
little easier listening you want that
show you can share with a friend who
doesn't really get Ramsay know Ramsay
that's a perfect little uh appetizer if
you will for the Ramy Universe you know
what another little great appetizer um I
have a kids book called I'm glad for
what I have and it's pre-order right now
so if you have friends that you're like
oh it would be great to like teach you
know about it's about contentment and it
has little animals at Rhymes it's very
short Illustrated beautifully
Illustrated so if you have a friend
that's going to have a baby or you're
going to a baby shower or maybe like a
birthday party you can like put that in
the kids gift and then the parents be
like this is a great message we should
talk about money more and then you can
introduce them that's what we're trying
to do here is just secretly get you to
talk about money and influence your kids
and your adults in your life and the
people that you love so yeah go to Ry
solutions.com and the store you can
pre-order I'm glad for what I have I
can't wait to read it to my little look
at the look at the pictures in that
YouTube people you get to see a little
bit is it not just beautiful it really
is I can't wait to read it to M at what
age can kids understand you reading to
them oh you know not like fully
understand but what age you start
reading to your kids I don't know James
has kids too six months a year two what
age do you start reading to them no do
they start understanding like 2ish
probably at what point is it not
pointless by the time you start to
realize that they understand it's too
late so just start early get them is
true that is probably true well James
has like Einstein babies they're like
Prodigy level just perfect children so
smart ah love it all right let's get to
the phones Roman is in Jacksonville
Florida Roman welcome to the
show hi my name is Roman very nice to
speak with y'all glad y taking the time
to do this I'm a disabled combat veteran
I served in Afghanistan that resulted in
me being retired from the Army at the
age of 22 last son upside down uh 14
years later I finally won my battle with
the VA of getting compensation for uh
those issues that I accr while deployed
W and I find myself sitting in a unique
situation I'm on the baby steps but it
is a daycare facility with no adult
supervision whoa here's the numbers I
make
$7,100 a month that's net taxfree
because of the type of income that it is
compensation from the VA and other
disability sources that's 8 $6,000
annually um the out of whack baby step
that I is most glaring is the house
purchase life as you can imagine with my
story has thrown me a number of curved
balls but I was presented the
opportunity to secure housing for myself
I have other debts but I was able to buy
my home from family for
$38,000 I currently owe $88,000 more I
pay $2,500 a month it'll be paid off
February 20 23 awesome that's a huge
chunk 24 that a few months yes that's
what I meant 24 I wrote the wrong Year
I'll you're good um outside of that debt
I owe about 30k on a car and I have
$6,300 in credit card debt if I follow
your one through seven steps which I've
not obviously paying off the house in
this manner you know that would come
later but I I had to do it the house is
valued at 268,000 with the got a great
deal
it's from an yeah it's within the family
but done the proper way so I find myself
burdened by that large payment each
month but that burden comes from poor
management of my funds so my question is
pretty much hearing that knowing that
I'm trying to pursue these steps how do
I what do I
do what's your house payment right now
just the actual payment itself without
the extra not 2500 even
oh okay you're not putting extra that's
just what it is I'm buying it from my
uncle who owns it free and clear and I'm
paying 2500 monthly I have three more
months 3.2 more months got it so this is
like a handshake type deal this is not
your traditional loan correct no
mortgage no interest no nothing okay and
you guys agreed it's going to get paid
by this time oh yeah I've got it I've
got it in contract with him I I was not
doing anything else well financially and
I committed to myself I will put down
roots and have a stable safe place for
myself if that's the only Bill I pay
okay I you know it got to that point so
I stuck to it never missed a payment
don't intend to where's the
other you know four and a$ four and a
half thousand
going so right now I'm 7180 is my income
my bill pay goes $2,500 to mortgage I
pay uh $825 in alimon and child support
I have 253 auto insurance 154 home
insurance you know cell phone
bill car note and then you know what's
how much you own the car I'm sorry uh
how you owe 30,000 how much is it
worth uh I could sell if I sold it today
18 so I'm 10 under and what's the
payment 612 a month okay well I think
there's still a bunch of money left over
you may be better off in your weird
situation that you find yourself in
having to pay this mortgage back to your
uncle is put extra on the mortgage get
rid of it as soon as possible to free up
2500 bucks to then attack the car and
the credit
card which puts me right back on track
with the baby steps yes yeah
without ofing the house thing out but
then doing everything one through other
numbers yeah yeah well because if you
you can't really you know you you got to
keep making this mortgage payment you
could start attacking your Consumer Debt
and you still have this going on but in
your shoes with this big old mortgage
freeing that 2500 up fast could work to
get rid of your other debt faster so
either way you're fine if you want to do
2500 on that mortgage any extra money
you have left over put towards your
start with your credit card knock that
out then move on to the car alone finish
that out right uh you'd still be okay
either way I think if you did the math
it'd probably be it wouldn't be much
difference got it awesome well you're
right it's a weird
situation yeah I you know I the one
comment I'd say I know you're busy and
know callers I I look for you know what
do you the investment question then
becomes a thing when it does come time
to invest with all of my income being
taxfree what's the best place to park
those
funds when I have no other
obligations uh well when you're looking
at just retirement I mean I would do I
would open up a Roth does the military
have any
benefits in that regard not when not
when they retire you they say bye yeah
up until then yeah outside of your
traditional retirement plans you've got
the IRA so I would open up a Roth IRA
max that out every year that's going to
put you you know 6,500 bucks it'll go up
every year and you got catch-up
contributions after 50 how old are you
37 okay so you got plenty of time which
is great and having no payments at your
age I mean you'll be debt free shortly
not working right Roman this money is uh
correct this this comes unless I commit
a felony and go to federal prison let's
avoid that let's avoid that well Roman
thanks for your service and and all
you've done thank you absolutely and the
the other places you could invest is
outside of retirement in a brokerage
account you know you could invest in
index funds over there you could also
get into real estate if you want to get
a save up and get yourself a paid for
rental property or something like that
that's another great Avenue to build
wealth yeah Winston I we opened up just
a mutual fund just a gross stock mutual
fund and put some extra savings in there
it's not tax you know you don't get the
tax benefit like a Roth but um but
that's a place we just put some savings
and if we ever need it we're able to
without penalty you know be able to get
it but we just let it sit in there and
have the growth too so yeah good Factor
there is you will have you know your
taxes on the gains so some to think
about with short-term gains long-term
capital gains but it's a great place to
invest outside of retirement there is a
it's nice having that bucket on top of
retirement cuz you can't tap into the
retirement piggy bank until 60 that's
right so this is a great way to save up
for big purchases you know Dave does
this he gets a big royalty check from a
book or something and he'll put it in
index funds in a brokerage account and
it just let it pile up until he wants to
buy something yep that's right it's a
good problem to have yes that's great
Roman the traditional baby steps for
those wondering he's like I did this out
of whack we want you to be out of
Consumer Debt first with a fully funed
emergency fund of 3 to 6 months before
you start saving up for a home purchase
so that is the correct order because we
find people that get into homes before
they should with a pile of debt on the
other side leads to a more stressful
life yep you become house poor and that
house becomes a burden instead of a
blessing and that's not the American
dream that becomes the American
Nightmare real quick this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netw Suite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us net week worked for ramsy and it
will make a difference for your business
too join the more than 34,000 customers
who trust netsuite to help make them
smarter and make better decisions and
level up their operations to learn more
get a free product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cruz this
hour good news for those of you who love
a survey the Ramsey Show annual listener
survey is now live and this really is
one of the most helpful things for our
team all the personalities We Gather we
look at the data what you guys are
saying and it actually affects the show
and so please let us know what are your
favorite parts of the show what do you
like what do you not like what do you
want to hear more about what kind of
topics um whatever it is we want to hear
from you and there are two ways to
participate in this if you're a texter
you can text the word survey s Ur RVE y
to this number 33 789 survey to 33 789
or you can go to ramsy solutions.com
slss survey if you're more of a web
browser type either way is fine it'll
get to us and if you sign up today
you'll be entered to win a $500 gift
card just for taking the survey and
letting us know your thoughts so go take
that survey today survey to 3378 n ramsy
solutions.com
survey the number to call if you want to
jump in is 8825 5225 Julie has chosen to
do so and she's in Austin Texas Julie
what's going
on hello thank you so much for having me
how are you we're doing great we're
great glad you you called Julie Rachel
already likes
you I can tell she's so nice she likes
your attitude ni do what oh gosh I said
I can relate to you cuz you're a mom
like me it's not fair I can't be a
mother I'm kidding oh they're amazing I
have um I have a primary question and
then I have um a few other questions as
well but my primary is I sell real
estate and so I'm I'm really good at
making a bunch of money really fast and
I'm not so great at keeping that
consistent so um the last three or four
years of my career I've been living on
Gross commission income and not net and
so I'm in trouble with the IRS um oh boy
so I I owe the IRS
$150,000
holy on my home and I'm wondering if I
need to sell my
home um in order to take care of that um
this last summer we had a series of
unfortunate events in our family which
has never happened before and that was
multiple car accidents at different
times which depleted our savings account
our HSA and medical savings and so we're
really starting back at Baseline for
savings as well um and so I feel very
vulnerable just even calling today and
and asking like where do I even start um
so thankfully um our our debt is
relatively low um and I have $60,000
coming in for income the next three
weeks um when these unfortunate events
happened in our world um Late July early
August the the like mail in the wall for
for us was my real estate income
everything that was in estro which was
about five
transactions like exploded they fell of
escro for a variety of different reasons
and I didn't have any income coming in
um until just now this month um so we
were able to pay and cover all the bare
minimums we cut our budget in half do
all the half toos I mean we got down to
Bare Bones um and proud of us for doing
that um my husband and I okay what does
he make we have three teenagers uh he
makes 84
okay and I sell about 10 million a year
which brings in growth about 300 um but
again it's not consistent and I think
that's I would say I'm more comfortable
saying 8
million so we talking anywhere between
two and two and 300K is fair correct for
the last few years
okay um has the IRS been in contact with
you like are they what are they
saying so um I don't know if this was
legit or not but I I had a company help
me get on a payment plan
with the IRS and I I can't locate them
anymore I paid them two or three
thousand to get me on a payment plan and
um I I'm just I'm so embarrassed I it's
okay I feel bad yeah no no well when
you're in a vulnerable state like that
and you're desperate you kind of just
make decisions and usually in hindsight
you look back and you're like oh wow my
desperation drove some of those unwise
decisions right but when you're in that
pinch you're like what's anything I can
do to help the situation so um
that I understand how how that happens
but um okay so the little bit of debt
that we have left we've got 25,000 in
credit card partially a lot of that was
put on just so we could make it through
these last few months
um car we've One car loan at $66,000 and
then student loan 15 and then that's it
okay okay well the great thing is Julie
you guys make great money um I would
move this IRS debt to the front I would
I would say current on the student loans
and the car and the credit credit cards
but I would not be paying extra on
anything I would pay minimum payments on
all of those and I would put as much as
I could towards this IRS debt the IRS
debt is always kind of the red flag debt
when we hear people um because they can
garnish wages I mean they're it's insane
right so like we want them out of your
life as soon as possible it gets a
FastPass to the front of the line it
does get a FastPass to the terrible ride
analogy for Rachel thanks I appreciate
that George the light in the mood um so
the 60 so what I would do Julie honestly
cuz you're amazing like you're an
incredible what you do obviously the
market isn't necessarily on your side
right now like it's been probably in the
last like three years um so you're
probably feeling a little bit of that
but if I were you guys your husband
makes great money I would just say hey
let's just you've already cut your
lifestyle in half what's the Bare Bones
we could live on CU if you guys could
find a way to live on 70 right that
frees up 14,000 of his income all of
your income and together you guys could
get this debt out you know within a
within I don't know a year 13 months um
if you guys really really and if you
hustle Julie if you were like all right
I am I laser focused um you know if you
guys called me and you were making 70
and that was it then then there's there
may be some really big conversations
we'd have to have but I I don't know
George you Chim but I feel I'm going jul
you're going to make 150 Grand in six
months potentially right yeah I really
shifted um after everything stopped I
expanded the market that I was in and
just took anything that was coming in
and and it's the fruit is here good yeah
um so that's the deal think about it
this way in six months you could have
this IRS debt paid off but here's the
key that money from your real estate
doesn't even touch your life it hits
your bank account it goes right to the
IRS that's it that's what you want me to
do yes like put that as primary every
single scent you make from Real Estate
right now go to the IRS in 6 months the
IRS debt is paid if you make 150 gross
right now we still have to worry about
taxes for the future income you're
making but then we can knock out your
other debt you've got what
another 30 how much do you have total 25
6 and 15 so you got 46 in Consumer Debt
after the car first yeah so just knock
out smallest to largest balance from
there that's probably going to knocked
out three months later are you guys um
budgeting Julie at all you and your
husband oh yes um we have weekly budget
meetings now this is all new for us like
the last Yeah couple of months do you
guys do you guys use every dollar our
budgeting app I do I I do because it's a
daily going through our bank account
he's wired differently and likes the
spreadsheet okay okay no that's good um
I just want to make sure yeah that um
that you guys have some kind of plan
that you're doing that's going to be
helpful too um and it's going to be
uncomfortable Julie I mean I know you
already feel that with already cutting
the lifestyle down but um but you're a
high producer I mean you're you're
amazing of killing doing so well with
your work so income wise I'm not worried
about you guys because you're bringing
in great income yeah a year from now you
you could be completely debt free with
an emergency fund so I think the thing
is Julie it's it's now up to Julie and
your husband to like look at yourselves
and I'm sure you have just to be like
okay we the problem like we shouldn't be
in this situation because we make great
money and so making sure our taxes are
done correctly is very important and
then making sure we live within our
lifestyle and when you do that um it
changes the game like you guys will be
able to actually enjoy your money that
you've worked really hard for and you
know you you shouldn't have to depend on
credit cards to make ends meet anymore
you shouldn't have to you know take out
a car loan for a car like no no more
live in Lita Loca it's over I'm sorry
but here's what you do need to do go get
in touch with a ramsy trusted taxpro at
ramsy solutions.com they can help you
navigate this you don't need to get on a
payment plan with some sketchy compan
they'll help you navigate this but it's
time and from now on quarterly estimated
payments that is how you avoid the IRS
down your back and how you stay on top
of this stuff for anyone out there who's
on that kind of commission type job this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
[Applause]
apply
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by my good friend
Rachel Cruz it's a free call at
5225 Dale is up next in Birmingham
Alabama Dale welcome to the
show hi guys um I hope these are easy
questions for you me too man I can't
take anything today great what's going
on um I am 57 years old um my salary is
143 and I have the retirement
bug my wife will be 63 the end of this
month and she works part-time and makes
between 15 and
18,000 we've met with a local uh Social
Security advisor and he is a fiduciary
but he made some suggestions that I
wanted to run by you guys
okay first the first he thinks my wife
should go ahead and apply for Social
Security at
63 instead of
waiting he thinks that the Social
Security Plus her part-time salary will
keep her out of that 50% penalty what do
you guys think about
that to have her take Social Security
earlier at
63 yes at 63 what's she gonna do with
the
money um save it so invest it
because you guys don't need it to
live no no no we we're completely bit
free the kids are grown and gwn awesome
what's your total Nest
Egg uh just a little over a million
awesome good for you guys yeah that's
great I'm going to use that amazing
income you have to try to Sock away as
much as I can in these tax advantage
retirement plans in the meantime but my
thoughts around Social Security Rachel
might have different thoughts but I like
taking it early if you're going to
invest it because investing it even
though it's a smaller pile of money you
get every month investing that will
generally uh cause you to be in a better
financial position in the long run
versus waiting and taking it later and
also it'd be nice to know if you know we
knew our our death day that would really
help us crunch the numbers accurately
but we don't we don't know when the good
Lord is going to take us so that's part
of the equation here well part of me
wants to know for planning but part of
me doesn't want to know so yeah exactly
that's true so yeah I don't it doesn't
sound like they're giving crazy advice
to go ahead and take Social Security at
63 yeah if you're able to kind of have
that principled approach though because
again you know if you take it early
you're getting that you're getting the
smaller amount and if you go just spend
it then it feels like oh my gosh it
could have been it could have been
higher later but yeah but if you invest
it then you're actually going to end up
making more and it's in your hands which
is great um so yeah that's I'm with
George on that one
um okay my next question is with my
salary i max out my 401K with catchup
contributions good I max out my HSA i
max out a raw good and the the financial
adviser is wanting me to start taking
some of that out using the rule of 55 so
that I don't pay the excise tax but to
start putting that into annuities and
just go ahead and take the H the tax hit
now but he's telling me that'll be
better in the long run when you running
out with theity that part feels fishier
to me I'm not saying that they're giving
you terrible advice but I'm generally
not a fan of
annuities what what was his purpose in
saying hey put this money here take this
money out let's put an annuity to give
you future income what's the benefit
there
financially he he's pitching it as being
better having a tax advantage and he's
also threatening minimum requirements
distributions later on out of our stag a
little over 800,000 of that is qualified
money in a
401k okay what kind of annuity was he
talking about
here there's different types do not
recall there's fixed annuities variable
annuities indexed
annuities I know it is not variable okay
yeah I would my I don't want to speak
ill on this financial adviser because
they might be a great person but I
always wonder why are they pushing me to
this what what's their endgame do they
get a commission by getting me in an
annuity versus me pitching into my 401k
yeah that's something to think about yes
yeah and the in the annuity I mean a
vested
interest I'm sorry I I know that he gets
paid for annuity he told us the
percentage okay and there's nothing
wrong with getting paid to put you into
certain products but I just wonder is
that a piece of the puzzle yeah and
honestly Dale I mean like with annuities
I mean it's great cuz there's basically
like the you know you can predict
there's that um confidence factor of
what I'm going to get out but also you
can miss so much of that growth putting
it somewhere else too so um you guys are
just in a really great position and so I
mean I'm not keen on I mean all the tax
detail stuff I would sit down probably
with like a ramsy smart text I I would
sit down with somebody and dive into
those numbers because I don't want to
steer you one way or the other on that
um but I I feel like the plan you guys
are on because again annuities I feel
like are more if you're I would the the
only time I would even consider annuity
for me just from a mindset perspective
is if I'm so fearful of the market I
don't know what's going to happen and
just knowing that there's predictable
income that's going to be coming in and
it just is okay but you guys don't have
any place to have that fear because you
guys have done incredible you make great
money you continue to invest and so I I
wouldn't mess with a d
personally okay but I would get a second
opinion because again and unless George
you can speak into to it the the the the
Deep detail of all the
taxes um if there is an advantage there
I would get a second opinion and just
making sure this guy isn't just selling
you a product but well you also have
some Roth money as well so you have to
factor that in as far as you know you're
not going to have rmds there and there
not going to be you can strategically
start pulling from different buckets you
know your Roth account which is taxfree
your 401k traditional you'll pay taxes
on that you're outside of retirement
money in a brokerage account you can dip
into that and so there's a lot of ways
to look at this but I just I want to be
leery about telling you one way or
another to jump into this but it's it's
always a red flag when annuities are
brought up and it's being pitched by
someone it's at least something to pause
and really get a second opinion on this
because if you didn't do it Dale you
guys are going to be in a great position
just hear us say that you got no debt
you'll have a million plus and every
seven years if the market returns are
around 10% that money would double and
so at 60 you know 63 64 you got 2
million at 70 you got 3 million and so
as long as you're not withdrawing a
crazy amount on these retirement
accounts you guys should be more than
fine okay and well again this that's the
first time I've ever heard this annuity
spin taking money from 401k and putting
it into annuity that's what yeah that
was a red flag to me as well yeah it's
and my final question is if I am going
to have minimum distri uh required
distribution issues later on should I
cut my 401k back to just maximiz the
company benefit and no I I wouldn't
minimize investing because of future tax
implication I'm going to put as much as
I can in those accounts and we'll deal
with Uncle Sam later on and we can be
strategic about
that okay because there's certain things
you can do where if you pull from the
taxfree account you're not paying taxes
on that and then you can pull a little
bit from the tax advantage account and
so you can start to minimize and work
with a tax Pro on how to you know of
course legally do all of this to where
you're not paying a whole bunch of taxes
every single
year gotcha so keep keep working and
don't worry about problems that might
come up 30 years from now yes that's
right exactly Dale I'm so proud of you
man that what a beautiful picture well
of just what life looks like on the baby
steps you're what everyone wants to be
Dale just calm cool collected Dale with
a million bucks no payments no mortgage
payment we're good maxing out every
retirement account and owned a man
you're going to be okay making
143,000 that is a that's a nice story
Rachel usually people talk to us about
these situations in retirement and
they're in their late 50s it's sad
stories where they haven't done anything
it's hard that's right and so it's a
great reminder to start early and early
doesn't mean when you're 20 if you're 50
start today that's the next best time to
invest and so don't get yourself down
and go I missed the boat there's no
point now of investing in a 401k and the
other thing is a lot of people are
spooked by the market and the economy
and I'm heading into retirement Rachel I
don't want to invest but we've seen long
term the American economy is going to be
okay yes yeah I mean we we went and
looked and ran all the numbers even when
you go back out from uh when inflation
was like really high in the 80s to
events like September 11th or the
recession in um you know 0708 and so you
you can even start to map all of that
and you watch the growth still come back
still come back a year too late are we
boun back there still down yeah there's
still down times but that it it's the
long-term play especially for everyone
listening that you know 50 and Below
it's a long-term play long-term play do
not pull your money out of the market
please I want you to retire with dignity
and that means playing the long game
think long term that's the key to
Building Wealth this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel joined by
Rachel Cruz this hour and this is your
show we're here but it's really about
you so call us
5225 and if uh you're wondering is that
the same George and Rachel from Smart
money happy hour you would be correct
you would be correct we have a great
time uh filming and creating that show
just downstairs in one of our Studios so
check that out as well if you like what
you hear today Jeff is in San Bernardino
California Jeff welcome to the show how
you doing good um so at a quick question
about I'm I'm finally you know taking
your advice I sat down with my wife and
we're paying everything off now Yay good
job Jeff congratulations so um except
we're like way too much into that right
now but um uh right now my credit card I
should be having paid off in the next
one year right so um we had bought a
truck but unfortunately that thing's a
Lim in and we're going through that
whole thing and I'm hoping to get rid of
that by the end of next year and then I
had to pull out out of my you know uh
retirement account money to buy my wife
a new car because the other one's just
not safe to drive so we're now paying
um uh the credit card first because
that's the highest highest payment or
the highest uh interest rate so what's
the balance on that that thing is 30,000
okay and what other debt do you
have um I have the truck which is uh
24,000 and that's the lmon okay and then
we have my wife's car which is at
43,000 goodness gracious wait $43,000
for your wife's car but you took money
out of your 401k you said yeah so we
bought it new because only because I
know I'm get rid of the truck and I
should be getting the money back from
that truck whatever money I get from you
just said it's a lemon how are you going
to get the money back so the truck I
bought my wife my the truck is still
sitting in my driveway how much can you
sell the truck
for um well I got a lawyer already and
they're going to try to give me pretty
much what I paid for it there's a lot of
try and maybe and you sound very
confident this is all just going to
happen I'm hoping what if the truck is
worth nothing cuz it's a
lemon um well it's it's still brand it's
brand new it only has like 30,000 miles
and it's still under warranty okay it's
it's only it's only a year and a half
old okay so it's still under warranty
and I I fixed the transmission like four
times already there's a whole bunch
great lesson for those of you out there
who are going I'm going to get a new car
because it's so reliable not always look
at our friend Jeff you got credit card
and two car loans what else um that's it
okay that's end in the house how much do
you guys make a year Jeff um after after
taxes uh we take home about uh 150 and
if I do overtime we could get up to
probably maybe 180 to 200 okay okay and
why is it going to take you a year to
pay off 30,000 in credit card debt when
you net
um pretty much
because the the two car payments are
killing me me and what could you tell
your wife's what your wife's car Jeff
$43,000 how much could you sell it
for um probably pretty close to the same
it it it was also brand new at the Honda
Accord but we were planning on keeping
that thing until it completely tight so
well that that would be take year to pay
off your credit card debt we got to get
rid of
stuff okay you just told me the car
payment's killing you so this plan
this car forever just the two car
payments like when I only had the car
payment for the truck I was okay but now
I'm paying for the truck and paying for
her car and then my car is 11 years old
and it has 300,000 miles on it and I'm
afraid it may not last another two years
right um but I'm gonna drive it until
it's going to be too expensive to fix it
yeah okay what's your question today so
pretty much when I get the credit card
paid off and I'm then paying down my
wife's car I'm afraid my car is not
going to make it right and I have a
decent interest payment which is 5% for
her car and if I have to end up getting
another car for me should I put some
money aside while I'm paying off my
wife's car in case I do have to buy a
new car and I it's a higher interest
because interest rates are going crazy
high right now so should I then save
money and and buy
buy another car cash and just not put as
much money towards my wife's car it's
going to be a used car yep yes no more
new cars no more loans no more even
thinking about interest if I drive it
not even even Jeff no because you know
what because you know what you're yeah
because that car payment that you're
paying you're paying interest on top of
that versus if you had invested that car
payment you would have what was it like
$2.2 million or something I mean
millions of dollars so it's it's
mathematic Al it's a depreciating asset
it's not worth it no always Cash for
Cars always carh I am rooting for Jeff
more than anything but what I'm hearing
a lot of right now if I was your friend
I'd be like Jeff you have Justified your
way into every Financial mistake
everything is well here's what was I was
going to do and what if I what what if I
just uh drove it I think we need to just
cut all that let's start from scratch
and go hey clean slight we need to get
rid of these calls yeah and the good
thing is Jee you guys I mean because you
will be working over time so I'm going
to just have a little dream session
let's say you're making 200,000 you're
bringing home 200 I think is what I
heard you right you said you could bring
home 18 yeah that's like if I never see
the kid and all that hold on see that
feels also aggressive Jeff let's just
say 180 for fun okay so you already have
a car you have a truck sitting in the
driveway that's of lemon you think you
can sell it for 24 you think you'll just
that you have a you have a loan for 24
you think you'll be able to just go be
even right so I guess I guess uh the the
manufacturer already said they would
give us like I think it was 40,000 um my
lawyer saying like 70,000 so it was
55,000 so you're telling me you're going
to get cut a check for potentially
$70,000 um my guess is probably 55 I'm
I'm guessing it's going to be but this
could be a year from now we don't know
when this is going to actually happen
yeah that's true right so we don't want
I don't want to bank on that that's
let's call that gravy money later on
down the line but right now don't make
all your plans based on waiting on this
check yeah and I'm not that's why I'm
still just having it sit in the driveway
and just doing the payments but we can't
sell it until it's
fixed um until I figure out if you know
the company's going to buy it back which
it sounds like they're going to but it's
just how but in the meantime you're
making a payment on a car sitting in the
driveway yeah that scares
me
yeah like I said we can we can kind of
afford it but you know it's it's just
Jeff you know what that was that was
another justification D we need a little
ding every time you do one of those no
yeah I mean and and I wouldn't sit
around waiting on them to do something
if nothing has happened by January I'm
on my own I'm selling the truck I I'm I
don't care what the I I can't be paying
on something that is just sitting there
so no I would be I would be out on that
I would cut Life Style down Jeff I would
cut up those credit cards and you guys
attack that credit card debt but you
make great income work extra for a year
of your life go crazy and you guys can
have this cleaned up hey Jeff hang on
the line we're going to send you
Financial Peace University since you're
new to this stuff it's going to lay it
all out beautifully so that you can get
on a plan ditch debt and build
[Music]
wealth
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George camel
joined by Rachel Cruz our question of
the day is sponsored by neighborly your
hub for Home Services with the
neighborly app you have fast easy access
to any Home Service you need from
experts you can trust near you download
the neighborly app today to find and
schedule service with any of neighborly
locally owned and operated service
providers all right today's question's a
good one from Sam in Utah my wife wants
to buy a $1,500 stroller for our baby to
be born next year I think it's
unreasonable and stupid to spend that
much money that spend so much money on
it we are debt-free including the house
with a household income of $300,000 she
makes about half of our income and she
thinks she has the right to spend $1,500
on a baby after four years of
infertility treatments am I off base
whoa that was a loaded question Rachel
okay so uh does she have the right to
spin like all that language we're not
let's remove that just for the fun of
this even if she was a stay-at-home
spouse and made Zar I don't like this
language of well she has no right
because she doesn't make this or makes
this yeah it's not weird yeah she uh she
has a right because she's part of the
partnership of marriage that you guys
are in so she has a right to voice her
opinion and all of that right just like
he would um yeah you guys are debt free
including the house making
$300,000 I'm saying yes I'm saying yes
and let's be clear why Rachel because uh
this is an interesting conversation it
goes beyond strollers this is mad at me
for saying that yeah when people say I
think it's stupid and unreasonable to
spend that much money on a blank on a
car on a house and that what we always
go back to is are you doing it with cash
and are you doing it for the right
reasons or are you doing it with debt to
impress people right and this is not one
of those situations they followed the
baby steps they make
$300,000 now she probably looks at him
and goes you're going to buy a circular
saw from Lowe's for $1,200 that's stupid
and unreasonable and he's go well honey
I'm gonna instead of paying for this
project or renting it and she's going
I'm GNA be walking around town with a
baby I want a nice stroller to do that
with yes yes I know and and it is out of
all the baby equipment your car seat
stroller you know there's a couple of
these things that they get the wear and
tear you use them a lot so if you have
the money to get a nice one that you
love get the nice one and George right
in front of me I happen to see something
this is a special treat we did not plan
this but this it was not planned my wife
and my newborn baby are in the Lobby
right now and we have a very expensive
stroller on display that we maybe had a
minimal fight over what do you mean this
wasn't planned I picked this for today
cuz you were on and just had a baby it
was totally planned W yeah but I didn't
know that that they going be here with
the stroller Cher on watch me do show
was a cherry on top um are we able to
get a shot I think we're going to try to
get a shot of is holding Mia will she be
able to be in the shot she's on our team
that's there's my wife Whitney and the
white and then dian's in the Diana's
holding the baby the baby the stroller
get that stroller price is right we're
sh off stroller in there go can we turn
the yeah there we go okay wa wait wait
we didn't see it do it again one more
time one more time there's the stroller
this is an up a baby Vista V2 stroller
that Rachel and I talked about and I had
qualms with this Rachel yes you did and
we use you know gifts from family money
and all kind and part of our own money
to buy this very expensive stroller it
was not $1,500 but it's an expensive
stroller yeah but we've also worked
really hard and we've followed the baby
steps we don't have any debt and we
budgeted for this thing and let me tell
you when we're walking that baby around
the neighborhood Whit Whitney is like I
I feel like this is the Rolls-Royce of
strollers like she enjoys walking it's
so smooth and you know it's worth it for
her it's worth it as a new mom who's got
enough going on get the stroller guys
yeah you don't the guys don't understand
and so I'm trying to Grapple with it if
you have credit card debt and student
loans to pay and I mean you can fill in
the blank right lots of other different
situations it may not it probably
wouldn't be wise for you to do that your
money would be better off put towards
other things like debt and all that um
but being debt free having the cash to
do it having a having a great income yes
it's fine it's fine it's not like it's
an unreasonable portion of their world
if they were going to buy a $300,000 car
and they made $300,000 I'd say let's
pump the brakes literally we need to
think literally and EPA baby has a great
braking system doesn't it there you go
this not not hasht notsponsored but it
is known as like the bougie stroller
it's a great stroller and we had one and
y'all we have all three kids now cuz it
has the adjustable you put the toddler
seat the rumble seat in the front and
then you get the little kick down thing
for the little one all of it that thing
went with us for six plus years yeah and
it was great there you go so there you
go cuz listen y'all we talked so much on
this show about sacrificing your
lifestyle to get out of Deb because
that's normally what people call in for
that they're deeply in debt and they're
like we want to get out and it requires
sacrifice so we're the people that are
always like don't go out to eat don't go
shopping you got to pay this debt off
that's the
and when we get a question like this we
celebrate you can do it this is when you
can spend you live like no one else so
later you can live and give like no one
else and those of you on baby steps four
five six seven enjoy that that your
money too at that point especially you
all in baby step seven still people are
like oh I feel like I still feel like I
have the rice and beans mentality I
can't I you know it seems weird to spend
and it's hard for me to spend all of
that enjoy your money when you've worked
that hard to get get to that place
you're free from that like you can enjoy
it so you want to be always giving
always saving and always spending wisely
and yep so Sam you lose this one buddy
you lose we have I don't have a t of
empathy here we're on your wife te to be
fair I was Sam at the beginning when we
were starting to like add things to the
registry and it was getting overwhelming
it feels crazy yeah yeah cuz and again I
don't know what strollers cost these
days yeah and you can get a cheat I mean
and those of you that are in debt and
you're having a baby you can get fine
strollers that are way less expensive
and they and they're going to be okay
and you know what Sam if you want to
split the difference go to Facebook
Marketplace and get a used one for 800
bucks instead of, 1500 if that's the
compromise that you guys want to make
but whatever it is you have to agree on
it as a couple that's important that's
right all right let's move on to the
phones Corey is in witch talk Kansas
Corey welcome to the
show hey Rachel hey George hey so I got
a question for you I've got uh 30,000 in
a CD I'm saving that for my
three-year-old daughter her future uh
would it be smart to take take it out
right now and uh pour it towards my
house and get it paid off in a year and
a half or should I just save that
money what happens if you don't touch
that money and you just pay off the
house with future income how much longer
would it
take another half a year okay so we're
we're arguing about six months here at
the end of the day yeah and is this all
the money you have saved for her
College yes okay no 529s no anything
like that not yet I just recently
started listening to you guys and we've
got everything paid off by the house and
uh I'm just not sure I I would like to
be just completely that free but uh yeah
I think Corey you can do you can do both
I mean like George said yeah I mean even
just say you took this money paid off
the house then that frees up a ton of
income for you to go and you know open
up another savings account or a 529 plan
and uh and invest and she's going to
going to be fine she's 3 years old so
she's I mean if she was 18 this would be
another discussion but there's plenty of
time for you to save or on the flip side
too Corey if you didn't touch it and you
paid off the house in six months longer
great you know what I mean like it's
kind of a either way you're going to be
fine so um I almost would be tempted
just to pay off the house honestly I
know I have an idea that could split the
difference what if you took you know
when does the CD mature you can take it
out without any interest
penalties uh March 2024 okay okay let's
say in March which one reason why I
don't love CDs but in March of 2024 what
if you took five or 10 grand and put
that into a 529 plan and then use 20
grand towards the
house okay and here's what that does bad
idea then you're invested in the stock
market and so that $10,000 that you put
in there could grow to 60 or 70 by the
time she's
18 but also you're feeling a little bit
of progress on this house and you know
you'll pay it off in a year and seven
months or eight months and so uh I think
it's splitting hairs but when I we look
at the baby steps 4 five6 are you
already investing 15% of your own for
retirement so that's where I get a
little confused so I'm I'm I'm doing 6%
my wife's doing 8% so we're at 14 right
now is going to do another percent Tom
cuz when you double the people you need
double the money so you both need to do
15% of each of your incomes to get to %
of household income I would focus on
that first get your own mask on now then
let's put a little bit away for college
each year might be 1,000 bucks 2,000
bucks any money beyond that let's start
throwing at the house and that'll knock
you out of this analysis paralysis
thanks so much for the call man is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cru this
hour open phones at
5225 Crystal joins us up next in
Hartford Conneticut Crystal what's going
on yes hello
hey how are you guys so good how can we
help you today well I've had my I've had
it moment um and I I am writing
everything down figuring out where to go
from here my biggest concern is with
everything that I've figured out it's
going to take me more than three years
to clean up my uh Consumer Debt okay and
I'm just worried being 46 years old and
having no retirement up to this point
pausing um my uh 401K with my company
that I'm at currently okay what's in
your 401k now I only have about
$4,000 okay and it's it's just been a
series of really bad financial decisions
with other 401ks that I had like I've
changed careers a couple times and I've
just cashed them out oh no and use yeah
and use them to for everyday expenses
living expenses as I was transitioning
into these new careers like I've made
two major career changes um and that's
why I'm a little nervous on
plaing uh the 401K well here's here's
some good news if you pause you can't
rob a a cookie jar that has no cookies
in it right so there's one Behavior
change which I think is what the reason
you're calling in today is cuz you're
like listen I've been living like this
for years maybe decades and it's time
and so that means you're going to have
to some radical things that make you
uncomfortable just for a season to get
this debt cleaned up so how much debt do
you
have I have um well the big big one is
student loans that I'm not even using
the education that I got you know so
that's the American story yeah I have
$66,000 in student loans okay that I've
been paying since 2000 on oh my gosh 23
years yeah ex exactly and I'm guessing
the balance has
grown I'm sure the original balance has
grown from from when I've gotten out and
I think I applied for the income base
repayment plan in maybe
200 three or four I want to say and it
hasn't made a dent I don't believe their
lies anymore that it's going to be
forgiven after you make certain number
of qualified payments you know it's it's
just a big starting today you're going
to believe in Crystal instead of some
government plan so what's your other Deb
that's
right um I did a big old debt
consolidation personal loan of 36,000
but it didn't that was like I didn't
change my spending habits after I did
that that's the problem with
consolidation y exactly it makes you
feel like you did something and then you
keep living change the behavior yep yeah
yeah so it's like up over 100,000 now in
debt what else do you have um I have a
car that's worth
17 but I don't make the payments on it
it's just in my name who makes the
paymentsense my
brother and he's okay with this is he
helping you out yeah no no it he's
driving it he just has way worse credit
than me so you owe yeah so you have a
car
loan I have a car loan and how much is
yeah so what's how much is that for
16,000
okay and um about 3,000 in credit cards
not really much in credit cards
currently because I whacked out about on
my debt snowball about $3,000 already
good for you that's great and what's
your
income so I looked it back uh last year
um and it's like 68 ,000 as a truck
driver okay uh take home take-home pay
okay so you probably made closer to
90 uh yeah probably a little bit under
okay um because we we get a tax credit
because we're we're basically living in
a moving house so we're allowed to take
a perdum credit for every day we're out
on the road okay and that's is this all
the debt was there anything we didn't
cover no I mean I and I cash
I cash if I can hear my dog a cash flow
vet appointments so every time I have a
vet appointment I stop and I cash flow
that okay now Crystal we are in a pickle
here yeah we make 68k and we have what
$125,000 in Consumer
Debt yep right and that's what my
concern was because it's from what I can
see like where where I've gotten my
extra pay payments is I've got it to
where I'm contributing at uh roughly
between 700 extra a month to the debt
and a thousand extra a month and is this
while you paus investing or have you not
done that yet I have not pause my
investing how much would be in your pay
how much would be in your paycheck extra
if you did that do you
know anywhere from on a bad week about
$90 to upwards of 150 a week that's per
paycheck I didn't contribute anything
per week so okay so we're talking
hundreds of extra dollars you can throw
at this debt yeah I know yeah that paral
six yeah so Crystal I think here's the
here's the thing if you number one you
still have time okay you're not 65 years
old there's catch-up contributions you
can do um later down the road but what I
would say to you right now is I would
rather not have Consumer Debt be
debt-free and then catching up with my
retirements then having money in a 401k
that I can't touch right now but I'm
drowning in
$125,000 in debt and so what you have to
realize Crystal and you have realized
because I've heard this on the call
which I think is so great is is you know
you have to be able to say okay what
I've been doing isn't working so now I
have to try a completely new plan so the
plan that we're going to talk about has
helped literally millions of people do
this and it's a plan with specific steps
in a specific order for a specific
reason because being able to wipe out
this Consumer Debt taking everything
possible right because I mean you're
scattered all over the place with some
stuff and so bringing everything in
actually getting traction for the first
time in your life Crystal like you're
going to start to feel it you're going
to actually start to feel you winning
not through debt consolidation not
through a loan that's sitting there
you're wondering about repayment plans I
mean none of that Crystal is going to be
doing it and you getting motivated to do
that and then I heard you talk about
like the different classrooms that you
grew up in and stuff like that and yeah
my family has always been a paycheck to
paycheck family yeah absolutely and I
just don't think I've ever learned how
to break that's right the habits of this
like I I know George just talked about
don't tie your money up in CDs well as
I'm going along I'm having CDs that are
maturing and I'm just immediately
cashing them out and paying good forb as
well yeah how much do you have saved how
much are in that how much do you have
saved I just did one for ,000 so I cash
it out I put that good for you towards
uh the vet the most recent vet bill
which I get the cash flow thing that so
the next one there's three of them that
are going to be maturing at the end of
November that'll be
$3,000 okay so here's the deal ch quit
playing with these CDs it's not helping
you get out of debt so here's what you
need to do put a th000 bucks aside in a
savings account and don't play with
these accounts anymore the rest of the
money needs to go towards knocking out
this debt and you said three years which
tells me you can throw $40,000 a year at
your Consumer Debt you'll knock out all
125 in three years right yeah that's how
I got it planned out is I should be debt
free in three years that's a great goal
anything you can do to get your income
up and your expenses down is going to up
that process so my goal for you would be
how do we get even more aggressive and
do this in 2 years 2 and a half years
and hold on the line Crystal cuz I'm
going to set you up with Financial Peace
University which is our which is our
seven our nine week course uh nine
lesson course which will help you get
all the basics and every dollar premium
I want you to do that too and we have a
webinar actually if you guys go to
everydollar.com budgeting to check out
webinars that we're doing to walk
through the budgeting process so Crystal
hang on the line I'll get you those two
things to start this because you're on
the cusp of change and it's going to be
uncomfortable but man crystal in four
years is going to be a completely
different person
[Music]
[Applause]
financially
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show our scripture of
the day Jeremiah
17:7 but blessed is the one who trusts
in the Lord whose confidence is in him
Cory ten booom said hold everything in
your hands lightly otherwise it hurts
when God pries your fingers open h
that's a good one Cory Timon she's
incredible uh the is it the The Hiding
Place have you read that oh back in the
day ohow great great book um great
generosity real um true or true story
back um yeah Cory timin love that quote
though so good yeah you should steal
that one Rachel not steal but give with
credit I should whenever you're talking
about generosity it's a great way to
look at it all right let's get to the
phones Julie is in Vancouver British
Columbia all the way let's go Julie
what's going
on um hi there I've had a a bit of a
rough go lately and I'm trying to look
for some advice on uh on the next steps
forward okay what's been going on I um I
have two small kids and unexpectedly um
my husband decided to exit uh the
situation um back in July oh my gosh
Julie I'm so
sorry that's okay things happen um
anyways uh you know he left the country
so I won't be getting any child support
and I did man myself yeah very
unexpected not not who I knew before it
was quick um and I I was able to get the
condo that we have um put under meon
parents so I I have that but I'm just
facing a challenge in terms of what to
decide to do because um the costs of it
are to me I'm I'm pretty good
far exceed what I should be paying and
what I can pay but at the same time
rents aren a lot different in my region
yeah and so I just yeah I'm trying to
get some advice on what I should do here
do you do you have family in the
area no no
okay um how much are you are you are you
working y okay um and how much are you
bringing in a
month uh about 4600 okay how much is the
rent right
now the mortgage is
2550 a month and an ho of 420 oh my
goodness wow yeah yeah says two-thirds
of your money is just disappearing long
time
um and in the area Julie have you have
you looked at other options have you
looked around to see what else is out
there I I've I've certainly I've I've uh
I've looked at rents and uh if you're
real lucky you might get a very rough
looking basement apartment for about
2200 2400 and that's that's something I
don't really I love to put my kids in
yeah um but and there's also I the
reason I want to buy initially was
because there's a lot of rovics that
happen around here where the landlords
you know they can find a reason to evict
people to to up the rents okay um so
that happens a lot especially to um what
do you do for a job Julie what's your
what do you what are you doing I'm a
program coordinator um and I I work for
a really great spot right now and that's
part of why I stay here and and um yeah
they allow me a lot of flexibility when
I'm with two small kids like uh I didn't
even get my my younger one into daycare
until she was two okay um because I
worked with her the first year you know
right now I got to be able to pick up my
kids from school I got to have them home
if they're sick and so the level of
flexibility I have to do that is a sure
and gold really yeah yeah no absolutely
are the prospects of getting this guy
legally to pay anything is that out of
the picture now yeah he's in a place
that they can't you can't get
him
interesting okay yeah his this country
doesn't have any uh any treaties or
anything like that really so but I just
still wonder if there are you know laws
in Canada that would require him to pay
yeah I can I can take it through to get
it put against like if you ever came
back but not not they can't actually
obtain it in any way
oh I'm so sorry Julie I I know you know
Canadian housing is crazy both rent and
mortgages and home buying but I do
wonder how long you're going to be able
to sustain paying this mortgage payment
if you continue making the same amount
of
income yeah yeah that's what I'm faced
with and and that's my how much Equity
do you have the insecurity if you sold
this place what would you walk away with
um 8600k
and I owe
430 okay okay so okay so you're saying
it would you would sell it for
600k yeah cost so you'd have about
200,000 in
equity yeah just 150 after fees and all
that yeah
um I mean I I I think month to month
Julie because all of this is so new
there's so much um stress that you're
feeling
I would want I I would need my income
freed up to have a level of peace and
that's not going to happen in the
current situation um I mean because it's
more than half your your your paycheck I
mean almost 34s so um Julie I would sell
it I would um I would sell it and I
would unless you can see your income
going up that's the only other factor
that would
change but I would sell it I would rent
somewhere for a year you you have that
equity and just to kind of get your your
bearings again um but there's also that
hard reality Julie too of you know what
the job you have which has great
flexibility which is such a gift but
what you make and the city you live in
you know we talk to people in LA or uh
you know San Francisco area you know
these places that are so high and cost
of living and they're and what they make
it you you can't you can't make the math
work and so um I don't want you to to
make that decision right now because
that's a bigger decision um of changing
jobs or moving or you know that would
have to be a decision you'll that you
eventually will have to face but I don't
want you to face that right now in the
middle of everything you've just walked
through but I think one decision you
could make that's going to just free you
up
some for me is is selling yeah
especially because your life
circumstances have drastically changed
and now that you're a single income
household a single mom your needs have
changed and your incomes change and we
have to face you know as John deloney
would say choose reality and the reality
is life is different this is really hard
and not having this mortgage over your
head will at least free you up and keep
you more Nimble as you take that next
step man I've talked to you only for
like three minutes Julie and my anger
towards him I can't even imagine I can't
even imagine how you're feeling but do
you do you have good Community around
you do you have a support system friends
or
family uh not a big one locally um no
but I'm where's your family I work in
mental health thankfully okay
yeah I I'm I'm keeping my head on pretty
straight um y it's it's more just that
that reality of of my kids you know and
what they'll have to in terms of you
know the life experience um is really
unfortunate sure sure yeah um and so
yeah you're in mental health so you know
but I'm like I just even from that side
of it um I wish I could just snap my
fingers and make this all fixed I know
but the healing process and it's a
journey um and Julie you're courageous
and you can and you can do this your
your kids are so lucky to have you
you're a really good
Mom thanks yeah I'll just pull keep
pulling it out it's I think I think what
what really holds me is I'm pretty good
at logic and and the numbers don't lie
it's just that level of insecurity you
know the reason I want to buy in the
first place for that safety that no one
can kick me out y ABS okay right but
that maybe is the reality too so right
yep and that makes so much sense I mean
grasping for
anything of control or predictability
right now feels so safe and so great I
would imagine right so so I understand
that that even saying to sell it and
find things somewhere cheaper that that
kind of uproots even more of that
chaotic feeling and so I do think once
you get in a rhythm of somewhere new and
actually having some margin financially
to go and buy it you I think eventually
you will buy another place Julie right
like this isn't just say you'll never
buy something else uh but it's going to
be within reason and it's going to be a
blessing to you and it's not going toap
in this about the cheapest in my city
1979 uh you know a little condo sure do
you have any debt Julie other than that
mortgage no no and you have an emergency
fund small one okay working on it that's
going to also give you some security and
peace as you step into that next phase
but man we are heartbroken for you Julie
and like Rachel said you're a warrior
and we know you're going to come out of
this on the other side but right now
you're in the real crappy part where
you're left to pick up the
pieces oh that puts this hour of the
Ramsay show in the books my thanks to my
co-host Rachel Cruz all the folks in the
booth keeping the show float and new
America until next time spend wisely
save intentionally and give
[Music]
generously
a